because the suns are reluctant to help
off of james so kuzma
was able to turn the corner
boy that should have been i think that
should have been a violation
absolutely that was a pass from lebron
james
kuzma takes advantage kuzma is just
three of 18 from the field in the series
so far but knocks down the three and the
lakers up four
[Applause]
[Music]
craig the former nugget who was acquired
from the bucks early this season
macklemore
three-pointers good how about that pass
from lebron
a jump behind the back
bounce pass and a elite seventh largest
here the early going monty williams
wants a timeout he's still upset about
that non-call
well james got hung up in the air and
made
something great out of nothing ben
mclemore
sticks to three from the att 5g
skycam this is the play monty williams
upset thought it was a violation
so who better to bring in than our
retired
nba referee legend steve jaby hello
steve
you saw the play is that a violation
yeah mike i saw the play and
yes it is a violation it hit we've been
talking about the rule here in the
replay center
for a few times here and it's really
kind of weird because there's a rule
that you can
start a dribble by passing out in front
of you and continue to dribble
but in this situation he was trying to
pass it to a teammate and then was the
first to touch it so by rule now
that should be a travel violation steve
i'm going to make you feel old
we just showed a graphic of your
officiating career you officiated your
first nba game 35 years ago
holy moly i didn't realize that and
you're making me feel oh that's right
mike
she's are you lame you look great
thanks guys but to get back to that mike
we all make mistakes as coaches as
players as referees
that's three points made up off of a
call that should have been made
amen oh james amen on that but spinning
on the slam
now the lakers go up by nine